[Music]  superheroes stand watch when danger  closes in  and save those in need but they have one  thing in common  they never show up in the real world  until ulysses  every superhero comes to us with a  purpose  we don't always see it at first  because we don't always know where to  look  flora what is this  i am ulysses born a new  holy unanticipated occurrences  did you type this  he's a superhero what  do you have any enemies i'm here about  the squirrel danger lurks everywhere  is he he's flying  [Music]  there was a change in the air  and the world was filling with  excitement  who's hungry  fun now come on  people look to the skies for someone to  save them  so the universe sent us  ulysses  can you talk okay that's not really  talking but still  you